c'était un poisson les arts
d'environ deux mètres et la faillite des
jours pour l'extraire et le nettoyer je
n'avait que 11 ans à l'époque
il est au british muséum celui là était
spécial mademoiselle à rennes j'ai
beaucoup entendu parler de vous par les
membres de la société géographique de
londres qu'est ce que vous voulez
monsieur
[Musique]
ma femme elle ne se porte pas bien
depuis quelque temps elle souffre de
mélancolie
j'aimerais que vous accompagne lorsque
vous étudiez le visage qu'elle apprenne
devant
je
et pas besoin d'une apprentie je paierai
ce qu'il faudra pour des rencontres
privées c'est pas un travail facile
[Musique]
je déteste l'eau
m
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ce compte nos
touristes
magnifique
je suis ravi que nous vous soyez lié
d'amitié
ce que c'est
quelque chose
rien
[Musique]
veux pas retourner à la vie qu'ils
avaient avant de te connaître et ma vie
à moi
[Musique]